I don't know how this became my life but
d-roc just won't be up on a text saying
we need a question of the day for the
vlog so a [ __ ] me B question of the day
[Music]
hey guys um sitting here at the airport
in Hong Kong on my way to Singapore
wanted to tell you about a keynote I
gave a beautiful my homey Shawn Doris at
bid summit
feel-good stuff this is really made for
everybody actually this this could be
one of the more valuable day only is
because if you consume my content on
YouTube a lot of you has aspirations to
succeed in a YouTube environment and
this was clearly and I mean clearly a
creators oriented talk when I when I
give talks a lot of my talks right now
are about marketing and and businesses
leveraging the current state of
attention this was a very different talk
a very different Q&A had some good
moments
the cuties d-roc the cuties are always
incredible right yes
playing here
just jamming on my email
you know like I've got a prep for this
call in two minutes
all right you know I worked you rock
[Laughter]
gotta have some fun on these [ __ ]
24-hour flights or travel schedules
anyway nonetheless this is a standout
episode for anybody who wants to become
a crater become a YouTube channel take
advantage of the current state and
really this is a interesting keynote
that sets up crushing it by book coming
out in January and so I hope you enjoy
it oh we can put a link mike has been
very focused on this very focus point
again the record is very good but uh
soon we will do the crush again push
push anyway
watch this keynote I enjoy your Gary Vee
time Mike I think I'm Mike I think I'm
good thank you you just you let me know
if you need anything I appreciate it hey
it's great to see all of you really
excited to be here and really excited to
focus on a couple of different things so
I really want to go into Q&A so where
are the mics I just want to get a sense
of where the mics are do we have runners
or do you guys have they're gonna be in
the aisle okay cool
so feel free to jump up at any point and
get into the Q&A I mean really from my
standpoint this is super unique kind of
conference because there's so many
people here that I know have known for a
long time back in the day have watched
from afar cheer for to be successful and
I think it's a super interesting time
for this conference to be thrown because
I think for a lot of you for a lot of
you it there's an intuitive
understanding that were in a moment in
time right for me I've been very lucky I
think I trade on moments in time I knew
in 1996 seven that this internet thing
was gonna be something
and my dad's liquor store had to take
advantage of it I knew that this email
thing blew my I mean there's a lot of
youngsters in here how many people here
were on email in 1997 raise your
awesome so a lot [ __ ] okay you know I
had 91% open rates on wine libraries
email service in 1997-98 and that was me
selling wine on this new thing called
email that didn't cost me money to make
a catalog to send it in the mail and it
was instantaneous the second the wine
came into the store it was out the door
it might be tough for people to
understand how holy [ __ ] that was and
it's basically the same way I feel about
this entire audience right now in this
moment you know the the influencer thing
has been around a long time you know
like when when I first met cue Park like
in in my office years it's six seven
years ago and telling all these vine
kids like you're gonna be famous like
this is real I remember their feedback
to me was very much like are you sure
like you know like you know some of them
were like yeah but not to the level I
think that I spoke to the conviction it
was only because I'd already lived that
three four years earlier I started a
YouTube channel in 2006 right my wine
show was there and that was on the back
of watching what happened with bloggers
before video was even a thing online or
podcasts the first time it meant
something not this newest iteration this
is the same old game for ever and the
biggest thing that I want to get across
to every single person here is regret my
entire talk right now is gonna be about
regret if you and let me explain what I
mean by that I'm not sure that was worth
the woo but I'll take it
it is my intuition that if you don't
squeeze the opportunity that's in front
of all of us right now as hard as you
[ __ ] can you will have regret if you
are smart enough and aware enough to
even be here today you are ready ahead
of 99% of the players in our society I
do not believe that people in this room
are quantifying the fact that they even
know this world exists and are willing
to take the financial and time
allocation to be here
big of an advantage that is how far
along you actually are because when
you're in the system it feels like
everybody's doing it you're amongst
yourselves the same way it felt like in
two thousand six and seven for me with
Twitter and Facebook like we all knew
social media but the world didn't the
influencers have the leverage you have
the leverage if you're paying attention
to what's going on in the world of media
consumption right now there are more
buyers of content than ever
Facebook and Amazon and Google and Hulu
are gonna bid for the NFL and the NBA
we are not down to three media companies
anymore if you understand how the chest
plays out in this game the only thing
that you need to make sure is that you
don't believe so much in the thing that
got you here that you stay on it too
long the vulnerability to this room is
one thing you figure out YouTube or
Facebook watch or Instagram or snapchat
or something else you win and then you
never innovate and then when that
platform declines you decline with it as
long as everybody here is religious
around creating and innovating in every
channel as it evolves and you stay in
the yes business how many people here
with brands or agencies raise your hand
great so for you you guys and gals it's
about understanding how underpriced this
opportunity is for brands right now
right and just following where the
underpriced nature is YouTube
influencers when I was buying them in
2007 8 & 9 were really [ __ ] cheap
right there were tens of dollars or free
stuff not hundreds not thousands not
tens of thousands and not hundreds of
thousands and basically very honestly I
have one pitch it's the same one it's
just pattern recognition where is the
attention of the end consumer and where
do people think it's overpriced or under
priced why do
companies and organizations spend
millions and tens of millions dollars to
produce television and film and brands
spend to sponsor it and what's that
worth versus me throwing dollars towards
many of the faces in this room even at
numbers that they can't believe they now
get I still deem as grossly underpriced
for what it is they get in return as of
this moment even the top youtubers and
Instagram celebrities I think are
grossly underpriced most of the time for
what they give in return which is
unbelievable levels of awareness and
relevancy in the world that we live in
right now I live in a world in my brain
that this is the only thing that matters
and basically nothing else does I don't
even own a [ __ ] computer like this is
it
I run a 200 million dollar media company
I live my life I have not had a laptop
for a year and a half I actually had to
do something the other day on a laptop
and it was like it was not like riding a
bike I was like what the [ __ ] you know
when you understand that this is it that
this is the remote control of our lives
and that 50% of the time spent on this
device is on a platform that delivers
content
IKS social network it starts getting
real serious real fast and I just want
to remind everybody it's not going back
this is only going to evolve forward so
I guess the thing that I really want to
get across a is I want to really do Q&A
because I want to answer people's direct
question because you can see my
pontificating anywhere you want anytime
you want somewhere on the web so please
take advantage of that and be I've
watched this over and over and over
again I did it q did it
we have these moments where we have
leadership and then we let it get away
from us because we take it for granted
and then we look back and we regret
I had leadership in YouTube and Twitter
my left YouTube for 6 years went on
viddler did other things like rihanna
wine business like this is what I'm most
worried about that you know it that
you're right you're here right now and
you're either not working hard enough or
not believing enough
how right you actually are and so when I
really thought about the talk that I
would give you're amongst everybody else
I just was like [ __ ] I'm gonna suffocate
the [ __ ] out of everybody in a very
positive way so that they understand
like please please please don't look
back at this talk in three years and be
like [ __ ] I wish I listened to him and I
wish I did a little more work created a
little more content took it a little bit
more serious because for the last decade
of this distribution disruption that the
Internet has done to our society there
have been people that have stumbled into
the moment that you're in right now
you're here and just don't realize how
far ahead they are because you're stuck
being used to each other 98% of America
has no idea what the [ __ ] is going on in
here
that is our opportunity and so I think
that we need to really take a step back
and start thinking about a couple things
number one context is much more of a
factor for your life than people talk
about we talked so much about content
and storytelling and that's great but
the lack of context that I see from so
many of you you take a piece of content
and you think just posting it everywhere
it's going to be successful is a huge
mistake please do not use all the social
media channels as distribution think
smartly how to make native content
within them in the same way that you're
gonna act differently here than you will
with your parents at dinner than you
will with your buddies and a weekend in
Vegas than you will in a business
meeting with the biggest CEO in the
world you're still you but you're
slightly different in all those
environment your content can't be
successful on Facebook and YouTube the
same way because they're different
platforms there is not enough religion
around us creators around context of the
platform too much is being put just on
the content and that is a very important
variable very very important so please
think about that too in a world where
there's a lot of people that should
stand up here and give the presentation
over me
when it comes to
nails and headlines and what I would
call growth hacking hey it's super
important but I feel I feel like
everybody here is either grounded in it
or knows its importance and will
continue to try to learn those tactics
let the one thing that I'm seeing from a
lot of creators in this room
specifically and outside similar to a
lot of the craters in here is they are
getting so growth hack oriented that
it's manipulating and diluting the
actual story and it's just about hacking
and getting the numbers which is great
for the short term but is the reason so
many people have lost in the long term
because they become mathematical
machines and their story becomes less
authentic and they become a character
sure of themselves that are basically
pandering to the growth in the category
they want to be successful in this has
been the single reason I feel like I've
had continuous success because I just
stay kind of in my thing and if it works
at the time at YouTube or Instagram or
snapchat
Mazel Tov and if it doesn't I'm okay
with that I'm okay with people having
more followers or making more money
because I know when I deviate you have
only a chapter instead of an entire
career so I implore so many of you I
understand especially [ __ ] hanging out
with everybody here it's like oh yeah
boring 4 million [ __ ] subscribers
like you know all that [ __ ] I get it
gets very competitive for humans I get
it but please do me a favor please
please please be religious to hold on to
your truths and your stories because
when you start diluting from that you
start beginning the process of you
becoming irrelevant it's important you
like that one it's good right
got an interesting one that I thought
would be a good theme for everybody we
need to ask more I get so many emails
and DMS from so many of you I like how
the answer is ask more how do you get
brand deals email every brand on earth I
mean this um you know I know some of you
have seen like me talk about like
Instagram DM like I'm getting 50 emails
50 emails a week from people that same
basic title doing the Instagram DM
changed my [ __ ] life a stunning thing
happens when you ask somebody says yes
so I think one of the biggest things
that is happening in this room and I
think about it is that people's egos are
getting in their way the feelings of
getting hurt when somebody says no hurts
your ego so much that it stops you from
even asking in the first place
it is stunning to me how much I like
when people say no I prefer when people
say no I tend to bounce into different
industries in my career because once I
become big in one and it becomes easy to
say yes I hate it so there's a lot of
[ __ ] fancy people in here who think
they're bigger than they actually are
and so I highly recommend that you check
your [ __ ] ego at the door because
it's the substantial aspect that's
holding you back from your next chapter
so please please please start asking
more more DM more email and 5149 when
you're reaching out to somebody that you
want something from it's a good idea to
start with what you're gonna do for them
I'm aware that you want $100,000 sneaker
deal I get it
the [ __ ] in it for the sneaker right so
people don't take for granted
subscribers or comments be thoughtful
understand what they're about pay
attention do your homework listen pay
attention to what they're doing on
social thirty minutes of homework can
articulate a far better way to have a
conversation with somebody that you want
something from thanks mom
distribution do not become completely
vulnerable to YouTube or Facebook
this is imperative this is SuperDuper
one of the biggest things that people
make a mistake of when they're but
always have 20% of your energy on
testing new things even when you feel
you don't have anymore time because
you're working so hard to do the thing
because the reality is what all I'm
doing right now if you if you go back
and watch this talk all I'm doing right
now is systematically breaking down the
things that I've watched for the tent
last 10 years that have helped that have
stopped people from succeeding it's been
you know it's just it's all these little
subtle things that I'm dropping on your
and these are the things that stop you
from succeeding which is what I spend
all my time on right stop the
vulnerabilities all of us are on a boat
with a bunch of holes and you're just
putting your finger in all of them I'm
just trying to give you the cliche ones
that I and all of you are going through
and it's just Universal and it will be
forever one of the great things is these
plaque listen especially for this group
YouTube and Facebook and Instagram these
are just imperative monsters until
they're not and what has been stunning
to me for example here's something
stunning to me it is stunning to me of
how smart this room is right I just said
look ninety-eight percent doesn't know
you're here you know like this is like
this is real in here and how many of you
have stopped doing snapchat like I have
at your lack of skill and here's what I
mean by that harsh statement most under
30 year olds are living on snapchat one
way or the other like the data is very
clear like it's it's not like you know
you could be sitting there Mealing not
true me and my three friends are not in
anymore
that's nice Karen
I'm talking about Big Data I'm talking
about the user numbers I don't give a
[ __ ] that you don't anymore or your
neighbor said something or the
thirteen-year-old girl down the street
said it's dead I don't give a [ __ ] I
care about the macro data and the macro
data shows very clearly that there's
hundreds of millions of [ __ ] on this
platform and just because Instagram
stole its features which by the way
didn't steal their features features are
not IP that's business
everybody here stole a ton of [ __ ] from
Casey and so and so it's not about
stealing it's about it's about features
great but there's a huge I'm giving you
little tidbits there's a huge
opportunity for so many of you cuz I
live on supply and demand of attention
and when a lot of people left snapchat
to only focus on Instagram stories
because why should I do two things it's
easier to do one or whatever other fancy
reason you made up that call it left a
white space for enormous opportunity and
I highly recommend shonduras comes out
of retirement and starts drawing again
and a million other things and so these
are the things that fascinate me
becoming too one-dimensional not
creating content native for the platform
and the thing that most is running
through my mind which is I'm trying to
get into the mind of this audience when
you have the ambition aka the audacity
to have your living be you just living
not having enough time is not an excuse
the people that have been sitting here
and saying like well how the [ __ ] might
you know I'm alright you want to get
paid hundreds of thousands and/or
millions of dollars a year running
around the earth
you have to quantify how amazing that is
it's obnoxious that it's actually a real
thing like when I if you go read the
Amazon reviews of my first book crush
yet that came out in 2009 where I talked
about all this people like get the [ __ ]
out of here nobody's gonna pay people to
like do things on a device like it was
so ridiculous
years ago right so please please
understand the obnoxious level of
audacity that we have to be interesting
a knife to get paid to just do and
please then deploy the work ethic that
is needed to actually pull this off the
biggest fear I have is for the people
that are actually having success because
complacency kicks in and you just get
into pattern recognition there's a lot
of you here that are winning and the
thing that I really most passionate
about is making sure you're challenging
yourself there's so much more to do with
what you're doing but it's only going to
be incremental you're only gonna get
paid a little more to speak you're only
gonna sell a little more merch you're
only gonna get a bigger deals a little
bit more it's still being creative like
to me one of the big things with video
creators that I'm really trying to
challenge is to start paying attention
to voice a lot more I think a lot of you
and again I know a lot of you and I've
watched a lot of people that use the
hashtag last night and thanks for the
dude that offered me a drink you know
but I wasn't here but you know a lot of
you when I went down the rabbit hole on
my flight yesterday just to get a sense
so many of you could be so successful in
podcast form but you haven't even gone
there so many of you could create such
an incredible Alexus skill or an alexa
briefing that can change the opportunity
for you guys as somebody who was there
from day one of youtube youtube is
mature Instagram is mature the next land
grabs the things that get you from zero
to hero or staring you directly in the
face right now the problem is some level
of your success is stopping you from
allocating time to take the chance on
the new thing that can dissin
fortunately leapfrog you three or four
spots
so please let's keep challenging
ourselves please let's understand what's
actually happening here please
understand how much of a ridiculous
advantage you have right now and how
much more you need to squeeze please
understand every thirteen-year-old in
the world wants to be you so supply and
demand is coming everybody is gonna do
this which means you've got to be
disproportionately better in the next
year or two so just like coders and
developers got paid a lot and right now
all their parents want their kids to be
developers which means it's actually
gonna be commoditized and they're gonna
get paid a lot less same for us there's
not a 15 year old in this [ __ ]
country that doesn't have this job as
one of their first one or two things
they want to do which means it's going
to be harder because the brands and the
Adsense and the merch is gonna get split
between 83 million people instead of 8.3
million people got it and you're only so
cute and charismatic shonduras so that's
the state of the union of this space I
would love for people to start lining up
for questions because I'd like to get
into more details so please do that and
when I see enough good looks like we're
gonna get there quickly we'll get into
it and and I know a lot of you came out
for this event because I about and I saw
a lot of the tweets ahead of time and I
just want you guys to know I'm
ridiculously humbled and thankful for
the attention and the admiration and I
really really really really have a lot
of heart for this community and and I
thank you for having me thanks
okay let's get into the good [ __ ] a
bunch of us here you talk about regret
and you talk about not doing [ __ ] and
I'm here I'm a small guy I own to small
businesses in Austin Texas yeah I want
to get better
good I know that this is an opportunity
to be first in line yes with about 800
people yep I'll do whatever I have to do
to go to New York even if it's scrub
your floors of my toothbrush is that at
all a possibility and well you can
definitely come and scrub our floors
with a toothbrush okay are you are you
gonna what's the second part the second
part is I just want to get better and I
know by doing that I have to learn from
the best I've been following you I don't
even want to follow you I just want to
follow your team I'm a creator and I I'm
just asking for that cool so Ryan do me
a favor just I'll Gary at vaynermedia
yes sir in the title put I'm Ryan I'm
the first guy that talked that they bent
today I talked about toothbrush that's
that the other thing and in January I'll
let you come and spend a week with the
team thank you sir
mr. Garre sir thank you thank you I am
awesome I watched a video about a year
and a half ago or so and my channel has
less than 400 subscribers but I hit it
400 more than zero yeah that's true
I've hit it with depth because I heard
you talking about depth versus width and
that alone allowed me to make over
quarter million dollars just within my
niche so my question to you is and I and
real quick I'm gonna stop you I
apologize this is super important so
many people are so caught up and with
anelia did a good job and understood
depth like there's so many people that
have so many more followers than me and
their book comes out and they sell a
thousand copies or when they're the
headliner of a conference half the
people show up that is expected cuz how
many followers they have which doesn't
allow them to command the price they
want for speaking or when they make
merch because Logan and Jake are making
a lot they sell a lot less death is
massively important and the number one
issue in this room is the way you're
taking your audience for granted the
amount of you that I audited yesterday
that have never replied to a comment in
YouTube or Instagram is baffling and
utterly disappointing right on is right
it's real you know because at some level
you know it's one thing if you want Fame
or the perception of Fame and that gets
you off and look great do it then you
should be about the numbers but so many
of you here want to pay your college
debt off or live the life that you want
or make generational wealth that your
grandkids have it it's gonna be about
the depth dudes got four hundred [ __ ]
subscriber made two hundred fifty
thousand dollars now maybe what he was
selling or having it's different that I
get it but that needs to be something
that people wrap their head around I'm
just stunned like every day every day I
get comments from people like I can't
believe you reply or how much time you
put into your audience and every single
time I get that I said it myself
I can't believe how much you guys don't
but just want to say again thank you so
much also some of the people that I work
with my clients they're your followers
too and be super awesome vibe
take a picture with you under one
pressure would it be possible for the
comic on the stage and do that sure
thank you sir
you got it welcome bro I've heard for me
thank you sir what's up my minute Gary
my brother thank you so much
consumes a lot of your content and its
really shaped a large portion of how
we're running our business right now so
thank you welcome my question we are a
jump rope fitness company so you type in
jump rope into YouTube jump rope it's
just all of us previously owned that
name loved it okay and so we're thinking
long term for a business are we better
off really
we're already some jump ropes you know
we basically only information around
people one by jump ropes should we keep
going into just selling jump ropes and
jump rope digital products or how do you
feel about brand integrations
advertising on our videos like for us
sometimes it feels like I got your kind
of photographer yeah I get it
so expansion is when brands get diluted
so for the first question I would ask
you is how much revenue is your jump
rope business doing and how big is the
overall jump rope business industry my
how long have you had the company two
years right my intuition is you still
don't have a big enough portion of the
jump rope world and so probably there's
a lot more to expand before you go into
other things but this is back to why I
Inc you know I couldn't have gotten
luckier with the two questions in a row
so cool I just got off my high horse of
saying I communicate with you and engage
right and like made you feel bad that
you don't what's really scary is I do it
cuz I'm selfish the reason I engage with
all of you is because I read everything
you say so that I could get better
insights to what to do next so your
answer to your question like I'm super
smart fine your community will tell you
you just need to ask I mean a man the
answer is literally in your comments you
just got to take the 18 hours of [ __ ]
asking
I appreciate a brother thank you you got
it Gary yo what's up man
Danny gold selling Silicon Valley we
chatted at relentless
I remember ya asked you the question on
a macro scale how to drive my real
estate block right but now I want to ask
you about the micro okay the local
because for me right now you know I
obviously Silicon Valley right there's a
lot of baby boomers a lot of Himalayan
totally a lot of older folks yes right
yes who obviously when you sell real
estate you have to list to last right so
getting these sellers to engage with
content or to view it right I'm a thing
so in terms of the older generation
right a lot of these people aren't on
some of these platforms that we're
talking about right yep so how do I
cause I'm I'm coming to you because I
I've thought about this for a long time
how would you recommend selling homes to
older people
well no no getting in front of these
older people in a digital you know in a
ditch on the digital platform so look so
look he's generalizing don't beat him up
so I know but like it up so look I think
that I think to both of your points
you're both right he's right I mean like
you know there's there's always demo
like there is not a high usage of 60 to
80 year olds on snapchat not just real
data you know and so a couple things
number one Facebook does not have that
issue when when I look at the conversion
on facebook 55 to 70 year old
conversions on Facebook are just
incredible like there's so much
attention there's so much scale they're
going through it more carefully and I'm
a very big fan so if you haven't run 5
mile radius from your open houses on
Facebook to that demo of 50 to 75 year
olds or 35 to 75 year olds with hundred
thousand dollar income levels or greater
have you run Facebook Ads aggressively
again
that I have so then the issue is you're
creative you know like I'm gonna leave
here right now and go to a berkshire
hathaway real estate pitch better that's
us for Boehner and like the data is very
clear Gina
so I think I think first you have to
look at your creative rights like is
your creative hitting the notes like if
you're in it you know the issue with
real estate there's a lot of people at
high-net-worth that are gonna look at
you and say you're too young and
inexperienced and not go with you I
lived it my whole life
now I'm finally going to the other side
so kind of [ __ ] sucks but you know
you know I get it like I understand that
so that's one thing to look at I'd also
highly recommend going down the rabbit
hole of next door so have you looked at
next door I have yes so I'm super
intrigued by that platform from a real
estate standpoint I think there's super
hardcore opportunity and then finally I
would if I were you I would do the third
thing is I would put 50% of my energy if
you want them to go old-school and door
to door direct mail like you know just
cuz this is happening doesn't mean we
need to force everybody into that
behavior I never give a [ __ ] what you're
doing I'm just trying to figure out what
you're doing you know I don't have any
horse and race whether you do VR or
snapchat or vine
you know queue and I loved vine but then
like it changed like I don't know like
it is what it is
bucket so I would spend a lot more time
in traditional than you probably are
cool thanks great you got it hey how's
it going Gary really well uh so when
looking to dissect a new social media
platform - yeah you're out how to be
successful what are some big picture and
practical tips you can use to dissect
that big picture is I would download
every social network that appears on the
top hundred 50 free apps in America
every time create a username and start
tasting it and then micro pictures start
creating content for it and seeing and
use your other social channels to drive
people to it to see what happens so like
how many people here are trying to
figure out what to do with Marco Polo
you know right so like that's
interesting like what is happening there
like how are using it
can you get 50 of your users to be part
of a group with you they're so big
pictures lean is like literally wake up
every morning and look at the top 150
apps in the App Store pick the 3 or 4
new social networks that come every
quarter every year download them create
your account start making content and
then go to the channels that you have
audience and drive them there and test
and learn look somebody landed here
eventually way back when and looked at a
bush with some berries on it right what
was the strategy somebody ate it some
dudes died others found strawberries and
so that's what you have to do with new
social networks Socialcam took a lot of
my time Socialcam took a lot of my time
in 2011 anybody remember Socialcam and
that five minutes right five minutes
right it was a it was number one it was
like nothing it came and went in like
three months I put a lot of effort to
build audience there it failed but what
I learned about mobile video on social
cam became the reason that I was able to
be successful at vine and snapchat and
Instagram and I was even successful as a
crater on bi and I just got close to the
creators that were successful but then
without that social camp three months I
wouldn't have had the IP of the dynamics
of video in that environment to make me
successful I highly recommend so many of
you were in the know business I don't
need another social network it's gonna
take away from what I'm focused on what
if it goes in and out of fashion fast
what it's the next vine it doesn't
matter what matters is the IP and the
learning and the land grab wallets there
if monkeys big for three weeks you can
do damage there got it that's the answer
seen hey gray hey Jay two things one I
saw you a couple years ago in New York
and your fitness plans working for you
looking good to is I run a digital
agency since I was young I started when
I was 17 it's grown year-over-year for
20 years we cut our teeth on websites
but I've got this gut feeling the
websites that kind of becoming
billboards and it's over the last six or
12 months I were in Northeast Florida
that being said Jake guys actually it's
weird you said that yes but yeah I
actually think one of the biggest
vulnerabilities in this entire audience
collectively is the lack of a proper
website collecting first party data that
you can remark it to everybody's living
so on all these platforms they're not
driving to their own domain where
they're catch I mean my email list does
damage you know may not be what email
was years ago but I've been trying to
make it better and better and it's
sucked for a while but now we figured
out like [ __ ] really give exclusive
content like really make it good and it
does damage so yes but ironically the
amount of people here who should have a
Squarespace earn about me or build a
WordPress for themselves and own their
URL is quite high yeah it's interesting
so the websites kind of stole the hub
for us but we're working on kind of
building those folks out of the wheel I
understand and probably last 12 months
or so we really started to pivot a lot
harder towards video marketing
communication was kind things a lot at
the bottom but thanks to you or North
East Florida so technologically wise
we're just a little bit there's not New
York City it's not Cisco it's that kind
of thing so if you're me you've got a 12
person team yeah growing yes but you're
looking to the future where are you
going what are you focused on okay if I
started vaynermedia today I would call
it Vayner voice and we would be an Alexa
Google home apple pod and podcast
infrastructure shop voice is the next
frontier yeah and I just started podcast
the video is about to get arbitrage by
voice like some of your views are about
to go away because somebody's gonna be
listening to something cuz you can do
two things when you listen yeah I just
started a weekly podcast actually two by
two months ago thanks for that advice so
glad I would go hardcore into that good
go take care of Jake hey Gary how are
you doing well thanks how are you first
of all thank you for everything I've
been following it for a while and really
appreciate it thanks I have a marketing
company that had started when I was much
younger
okay now we're doing what would you fix
yeah well okay we're actually working
with some fortune 500s now so we're
growing and yeah you know one of our
service lines that's been really
profitable for us and we have a high
retention rate on its reputation
management yeah so I know there are some
big players out there and we're going up
against them now but our retention rate
is crazy high we're very effective at
what we do and we're scalable we've
built it out in a way so my question for
you is I'm really looking for ways to
grow large quantities and scale as big
as fast as possible we're growing
because we're growing year by year
already and I want to see how big I can
take this and how quickly I can take it
as big as possible let me ask you a
question yeah the only way you can do
that is either raise money okay or start
taking a lot less money personally okay
I've already started on the second okay
but as far as investors I've been
approached before but I'm looking for a
more strategic investor someone who
would know what to do in this space and
most people are you know people in real
estate or family who under see the
opportunity but they won't be able to
really help me smart money you want a
smart money are you looking to invest
I'm not okay to ask got a scram you look
I think I think you need to decide
between smart money and passive money
okay I'm gonna give you a really good
piece of advice in 2001 and to when I
lived through in the business world and
in 2007 6 & 8 when I lived through the
business world I had a lot of friends
that were looking for smart money okay
and then the market crashed and they
were looking for money and there was
none to be had just keep that in mind
okay and what would you do with the
money where would be the avenues you
would hit I don't know what's your
[ __ ] business bro
like like all I heard from you is you
want to get bigger faster sooner
I asked why because I think usually when
when people's agenda is to get bigger
faster I usually know that they're in
trouble okay way to get bigger is to go
slower alright thank you
you got it I just expand on that just
cuz not to leave it with like a change
you know everybody's in such a rut you
know young Howard how old are you bro
Ilan how are you how old that's the
thing right like to me his advantage is
his youth which should allow him to go
slower not faster and I get it everybody
wants to win I get it but I know one
thing that you guys hear from me more
than most people talk about it is
patience I know it's the secret sauce
life is long and when you'd want to get
bigger for the sake of bigger you start
taking shortcuts that lead to
vulnerabilities so I just would keep
that in mind hi it's an honor to be here
thank you thank you for what you do so
I'm a complete newbie to the space I was
one of the 98% I just hopped on about
two months ago come on my my audience
that I serve or I wish to serve or
entrepreneurs who like me who struggle
to get started yep and so I'm building
that group in these platforms and I
don't really have much I'm building
Instagram first and then from there
didn't my offer would be you know
whether I'm affiliate marketing
something or selling courses and whatnot
so that's sort of my vision right now
where I'm also building network
marketing companies because I do like
network marketing and so I zero
it's just leverage I don't know it's for
fun okay
I mean do you it what are your thoughts
on that not as much of a fan okay but
you know just one man's point of view
just curious why I think the reason you
like it is because there's quicker
dollars in right now there's no dollars
it's just an interesting little
challenge that can actually grow look I
think I think when somebody decides to
get into content and creative and
already before they started they are
thinking about the monetization of
affiliate or network or things of that
nature you're set up to fail and so what
I would tell you to do if if if I have a
chance which I do is to take a step back
and realize you know creating content to
motivate people to start is a crowded
space a forever space because people
don't act I get it but what I'm worried
about as a newbie is this is such a
cliche story right I'm gonna build an
audience and I'm gonna monetize it for
me and what happens is when you start
before you start you're thinking about
monetization like how will it happen
when it happens
what that does is something very
interesting it creates the wrong kind of
content when the seed is about long-term
monetization the seed is corroded and
there's an element of that in all of the
content no question my biggest advantage
in the marketplace is the lack of
interest of monetizing my audience you
need to think about that coming into
this yeah I think the angle is to
blindly try to bring value to the
audience whether it's information or
entertainment and then wake up in six
years and start to then debate what the
[ __ ] to do with it okay so I've been
watching you for about six months now
but over the last year and a half I've
been building an Instagram and I've got
about a half a million followers but
since I've been watching you I've seen
probably a triple and growth just from
implementing different things I just
kind of put you on my on my nightstand
at night and I just kind of listened to
you Thank You Man and
happy - happy to be there I have me so
it's so it's really exciting better than
yesterday guys like listen I listen to
you all the time when I'm in the shower
I'm like cool no I can say I haven't
done that yet but what uh what I really
wanted to ask you is I've been building
this platform because I'm a firm
believer that you have to have an
audience to hear you and I'm a singer
before you before you release something
if you might want to create momentum so
it's less moment its its momentum but
you more importantly know its leverage
yeah and that's what we're kind of going
for because we know you can go into
labels now and I feel I feel confident
if we went now we wouldn't get as good a
deal as if we went in with the leverage
like do it like that you know what's
happening in the hip-hop space right put
out projects put out mixtapes have
leverage of millions of followers and
then get the kind of deal that you think
you want if you eat by the way you might
be the last of the Mohicans that even
give a [ __ ] they even have a deal
and that's kind of about my managers in
the audience I actually told him you
know I want to live every day thinking
that I'm not going to get a deal at the
end of the day you know what I mean so
do that and that's what and that's kind
of that's kind of a game plan that's not
fully where you're at right now no but
but coming into this this this time and
season where I'm releasing my first
single what would be your strategy
because I'm heavy on Instagram I'm not
so much on Facebook and YouTube and I'm
branching out I started doing that about
a month ago
you have Spotify in SoundCloud now I
have a spot I don't have either account
really set up this is the first time
we're going but yeah you need to do that
right and and start populating it you
know one thing that I think is really
interesting is populating an artist's
SoundCloud and Spotify with content of
them speaking about their thoughts
before they launch their first song and
then you could start siphoning you know
because think about it you're building
this audience on Instagram how many are
on Instagram now about half a million
right so come three months from now
tomorrow whenever it drops it's gonna be
the first time you're gonna ask that
audience to go over there whereas if you
had three or four months of getting them
to go over there with the journey of
your mindset before the launch of the
first album you'll have a much bigger
base that will create virality
instantaneously for you when you drop
this song there so you think that big
the big thing I did with crush yet that
was very unusual I apologize but I want
to give this to everybody the big
with crush it that was super unusual for
booksellers in 2008 was I pre sold it
for four months before it came out the
conventional wisdom back then was you
have your blow out week right you go
into today's show and Huffington Post
then you push an email and I asked one
question in my early meeting with
HarperCollins which was do all the sales
count if I get him in pre-order on
Amazon that week I get them or the week
the book comes out and they go to the
week the book helps out so like one more
time so if I get eight this week in
nineteen next week and forty seven next
week in the and they're like yeah at all
counts I'm like why don't people do that
because we lived in a traditional world
of you go on television and you get your
orders that's how I'm thinking about you
I know that artists now don't turn their
soundcloud or Spotify into a podcast for
three months before the first song which
is exactly why it's a good [ __ ] idea
yeah I was gonna say I've never seen
that done Spotify before but it I've
seen it's not make [ __ ] up yeah that's
what I've been doing for a few months is
how I came up with my viral video cons
and now a hundred percent that's what I
would do cool thank you you're welcome
hey Gary Hey with a small agency and we
spend a lot of our time trying to think
of industries and verticals that are we
want to get in on the ground level of
your own voice right now and you're
talking about that a lot yes but going
through about a year and a half worth of
your content you mentioned eSports a lot
I'm a fan but I wanted to get your
opinion on what do you think of eSports
from a marketing standpoint and also
from a VC standpoint I think from a VC
standpoint it's super dangerous because
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there and
I think that the IP game makers and the
players have the leverage and there's a
lot of people building businesses in
between they're gonna be vulnerable
unless they're run by very talented
people and they'll be not as valuable as
they're being priced from the marketing
standpoint I think it's grossly
underpriced attention and that brand
should spend a fuckload more money on
eSports and do you think that do you see
a possibility of an outside marketing
firm partnering with an eSports team and
just doing all their content or
it has to be no I think I think if you
guys are debating eSports as a place to
go hard at it will become fruitful for
you if you're good at it all right
thanks man
you got real quick shout out to D Rock
do you rock yeah hey Garrett house : it
is going super well bro well nice to
meet you I'm Parker panel hey Parker I
just turned fourteen years old and when
you were my age what were you doing to
make money and really crush it look what
grade are you in eighth grade
so in eighth grade I had I started my
first real real real business I was in
eighth grade I was making a thousand to
two thousand dollars a weekend once a
month selling baseball cards in the
malls of New Jersey awesome because I
don't know if you know this bro but
there was no internet when I was 14 and
so you know it's real [ __ ] easy for
you to make money it was much harder for
us old folk but we got by awesome
awesome well thank you so much
before you leave bro oh yeah what are
you what are you trying to do well you
know I'm an actor and I started my
youtube channel a few days ago was my 1
year and I do a bunch of comedy videos
and my family my dad's over there and we
travel all the time so we were just in
Dubai in the Maldives and I video my
adventures there and I really want to
entertain people so they can get out and
kind of do what you do and really change
the world and motivate them in a good
way
good for you brother I wish you luck
thank you so much here
so I feel terrible to have to follow
that thanks Parker yeah you're [ __ ]
Roberta [ __ ] pretty much like what else
is new right yeah how's it going Gary
really well it's good to see you good to
see you man
um so for context I'm a creative
entrepreneur and a lot of why I do on
YouTube is I try to help people not be
starving artists I try to like walk them
through why I did that work why I did
that did it why it sucks sometimes and
my question to you right now is for all
of those people it's what do you see
being the disproportionate vulnerability
for creatives and creative entrepreneurs
cuz right now I know you're doing your
vein or creative initiative you're
someone using the hiring chair yeah so
for all the creatives out there for all
the people whether during YouTube or
snapchat or whether they're drawing like
what do you think right now is the big
book is the big vulnerability what are
they under estimating that they're not
good at business hmm that pretty much
sums it up
but like beyond I mean the biggest
vulnerability Roberto is that some
people are such extreme just artists
that they don't have the humility in the
face of entrepreneurship being cool to
hire to team up and have a partner who
can drive the actual business so
ultimately your answer is they need to
either one invest some time and getting
rid of this if they have the potential
that they nerve tap or outsourcing
because it's like you know me well we've
known each other a long time I only
think that I can get only incrementally
better at swimming and singing and
painting right entrepreneurship is so
cool right now and such a pedestal and
has no cost of entry every person here
can put the word entrepreneur in their
Instagram profile and and there's just a
fundamental difference between a
successful entrepreneur and somebody who
says they are and there's a lot of
people here that are unbelievable
creatives who will lose because they're
spending disproportionate time trying to
be good at something that will never
happen
instead of putting a hundred percent of
their effort in the creative process the
fact that we're blending listen there's
people like Shawn Norris who's
absolutely and the reason I attached to
him and always gave a mentorship and
like cool this guy's creative and an
entre
there's a lot of people in here who want
to be an entrepreneur there's a lot of
entrepreneurs in here that want to be a
creator and that is the vulnerability
the lack of self-awareness and the utter
delusion and what they want instead of
what is real boom thanks Gary great to
see you hi Gary hi I'm Sara bathroom
Sara Beth yoga and I used to be all
about that hustle I used to work 80 hour
weeks and happily would work 80 hour
weeks good
so I guess my issue now is that so I
have a kid and I have another on the way
and so I'm much more focused on my time
management and ship earlier you
mentioned like you know when you say you
don't have time like I don't really have
the time together so I was purposeful
about staying on YouTube and Facebook
and Instagram I get it but I hear you
about expanding my brand and reaching
out to other platforms how look I think
I'm very empathetic look even if you're
the greatest hustler that ever lived I
don't know if you've heard it's still
only 24 hours in a day right so here's
what I would say sad I would say that
there's nothing wrong with staying deep
on Facebook and you and Google platforms
Facebook and Google rule the digital
world and there's nothing even remotely
close that's happening that it's gonna
change that narrative for the next 24 to
48 months intuitively right so I'm you
know in a world where you're have your
second coming and all those things that
are going on in your life I'm not so
desperate for you to have to do other
things right now knowing those knowing
that Instagram Facebook and YouTube are
going nowhere fast
right I think when I say to a lot of
people in this room you know find more
time it's as long as your ambition is in
check to your actions you're good right
you want to be the best mom you can be
you want to be a creator you want to be
an entrepreneur that's awesome the
biggest rub that I have is you have a
lot of people saying that they're gonna
build billion-dollar empires and they're
working nine hours a day and that's not
going to
app right so it's not that I want you to
spend more time as long as you're like
hey I want to make my ambition is to
make it's hard if you're gonna monthly
you know mother and not outsource that
to a full-time nanny to have the time
and energy to build a hundred million
dollar media company around yourself
it's gonna be hard as long as you're
cool and understand like hey maybe
that's a million instead of a hundred
million because rightfully you're
choosing to allocate raising your
wonderful children then you're good it's
the delusion that I'm worried about
it's that people's mouths are way ahead
of their actions you got it yeah thank
you you're welcome
hey Gary hi Brooke how's your day been
you're really good CJ how are you good
okay so I just turned 13 and I was
wondering like or I've been doing
YouTube for about two years yeah and the
first year I didn't really get anything
done oh good up until this yet anything
done as it didn't get traction or you
were bullshitting playing video games Oh
second both of them so but then this
summer
that's aren't you get more like I quit
video games and I got a better view time
and attraction yep but I'm still like
I'm at 142 right now so I'm wondering
like what's one tip you have for kids my
age one 42 meaning what 142 subs got it
so what do you want to happen CJ I just
want to get at least 300 by the end of
the year okay well first of all we'll
take care of that
[Applause]
right so like now what just to inspire
people good so if you want to inspire
people if that's real right if that's
really what you're about then you don't
need to do anything but continue to put
out the content that you think will do
that thank you
I think the reason I said like we'll
take care of that is what I don't want
you to do that so many people do whether
they're 13 or 81 so many people get into
the rat race of how many followers they
have right and like that's just not the
game that you want to play do you know
what I mean because the reality is is
that that's gonna dictate too many
actions you can't let your self esteem
or self-worth be wrapped up into metrics
on YouTube because it's one tiny proxy
and the reality of what you're up to you
understand
[Applause]
yeah we're gonna we're gonna throw a
right hook right now what's the name of
your channel CJ CJ bowling spell it
CJ pol ing slower because you want them
to actually [ __ ] follow you
CJ bol ing bol ing it would really mean
a whole lot to me if I've given you one
inch of value ever in my life for you to
follow this kid let's let's see what how
many followers he has on YouTube by the
end of this weekend yeah get in your
seat
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey I've only got a couple more minutes
just trying to be fair to the people in
line I'm not sure if I'm gonna be able
to get to you but we'll see how long you
let me sit up here go ahead man
hi Gary hey Tom I'm one of the 99 or
hundred percent of the people that uh
before today
my wife has been bidding me up to listen
to you just once yes
I kept fighting it yes I kept like [ __ ]
that guy I was I get it
I know how you roll done she tells me
that I think she's rude to me I should
wait until I meet you are you gonna beat
it up with me I want to ask you I
finally Johnny - you know what she's
doing I want to know what I need to do
to stay on focus on try and stay
motivated you know to move it in
generally yes she blogs about food she
developed food recipes yeah and
everything and she's but you're asking
for you how you stay focused yes
look I think listen some of you have
heard this for me this is such a big one
for me I've said it in a funny setting
and I've said it other times I just
really wish people knew that they were
gonna die Devon like how can you not
stay Botev ated do you know that the
odds of becoming a human being or 400
trillion to one oh great sit on that
[ __ ] for a minute
like we are so unbelievably lacking
perspective and are so not grateful for
what's happening here we so focus on
negativity and [ __ ] that's bothering us
we need to spend way more time on
optimism and good and all the good
things that are happening that will
motivate that I am completely driven by
gratitude every true day that I don't
get a text or phone call that somebody I
loved died or has terminal illness I'm
[ __ ] pumped so its perspective debt
like the [ __ ] do you have to complain
about
no I don't complain I want to make sure
I'm moving from the industry that I was
in yeah into what she's doing because
she has become very successful regret
man like you don't want to be 80 sitting
and saying [ __ ] I spoke to Gary my wife
did it this happened and I didn't do
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] let me listen I'm
gonna give you guys a huge huge
unbelievable hack one day one hour go
and volunteer in a nursing home it is
the great move that everybody here can
do first of all it's just nice to do
that and you give back and it's
tremendous and it's unbelievably
impactful number two thank you number
two you will get way more because you're
gonna see something that you haven't
seen in such a pure State it's called
regret you will face regret in a way
that will [ __ ] with you so hard that you
will stay focus and on track for the
rest of your [ __ ] life the number one
thing that you will taste if you go to a
nursing home is you will find multiple
people that will talk to you about
regrets in a way that will pierce your
soul in a way that you've never felt
before because they're actually in that
place where time has run out and it will
make you go back home and start cooking
for the first time starting a video
running like you'll start doing [ __ ]
that you've been pondering for the last
decade
after one hour of giving back putting
karma points in the bag and it will be
hugely beneficial for you so please
please please consider that thank you so
[Applause]
I still got to speak so like you know
I'll wrap up all the big important stuff
after you're done but what should these
guys be doing for the next 48 hours so
they don't have regrets that's a great
question so the reason I think these
things are good have nothing to do with
the content on this stage this is the
number one time to start putting your
introverts Elf on the Shelf to expand
your ability to network this is 100
percent ROI successful for you if you
legitimately go up to people you've
never seen before in your life say hello
and ask them what they're about this is
only about networking like you should
actually all leave and come to none of
the talks going forward stuff for mine
including his and network the whole time
I'm sure that's the guys the all the
real magic is you know with the best
talk of the conference with the third
best talk of the conference all of that
stuff all of that stuff is so stunningly
secondary to you getting 5 to 7 to 15
relationships here and let me tell you
something karma is practical I just said
in my last little thing doing the right
thing for CJ it's just super smart to do
[ __ ] that has no expectation in return
or anything to do we're in a world where
a lot of thoughts of collaborations and
things you do you're thinking about what
comes to you after you do giving without
expectation has been one of the core
pillars of my success you love it there
too you lived it for me like it's it's a
big [ __ ] deal please do it really oh
sorry I'm sure you guys won protip I
have I've gone to a million of these
conferences and talked to so many people
networked until I became friends with
Gary and this is how I did it when you
go to a conference you don't hang out
with your friends the people that live
in your state anyone else you talked to
as many people you've never met before
and here's the thing this can be weird
because I probably talked to you guys
yesterday this exact same thing happened
where it's like hey how are you what do
you do what's your jam learn about you
that's so cool like get a good read on
someone become friends follow them on
Twitter whatever and then it's things
their food around here I'm looking for
food right now Coubertin means that I
only literally go around looking for
food talking to people five-minute
conversation become friends then go look
for food oh I need to get a drink
where's Holiday out and you go talk to
someone else get that five into
friendship in and then oh man so I've
been looking for food as their food
around here and then you walk off
looking for food and go get that next
conversation like everyone I want
everyone to end their conversations I'm
looking for food and go talk to someone
new talk that everyone in this
conference convinced summit 2017 is lid
I'm not gonna adapt alright that's that
guys have a great lunch go find food
talk to everyone thank you I don't know
how this became my life but d-roc just
won't be up on a text saying we need a
question of the day for the vlog so a
[ __ ] maybe question of the day what are
you trying to be an influencer for or
what are you trying to accomplish with
the attention that you're trying to
amount for yourself or your business
answer me that
you
[Applause]
[Music]